Jessica Smith's father was an alcoholic
her mother raised her to believe in
Jesus and Jessica often turned to God
for comfort and security
I loved the idea that God was my father
in heaven and he fulfilled any of the
inadequacies of my real father in high
school Jessica decided to do what felt
good to her including experimenting with
drugs I wanted to be accepted I wanted
to feel cool I wanted to be popular I
wanted boys to like me later when she
went to college Jessica decided to leave
Christianity behind completely I just
saw people living these lives that
seemed goody-two-shoes to me it just
pushed me the other direction I just
thought if that's what a Christian is I
don't want it but spiritual issues for
something Jessica couldn't avoid dealing
with when a close friend was killed in a
motorcycle accident I had to know where
is she is there such a thing as heaven
and hell what do I believe I didn't know
if she knew Jesus and I couldn't stand
the thought of her being in a place
called hell
Jessica desperately wanted answers she
didn't like what the Bible said about
Hell so she felt compelled to call a
relative for advice the relative a
psychic told Jessica she could talk to
her deceased friend Jessica knew the
Bible warned against talking to mediums
but she was swayed by the emotional
experience felt like love it felt like
peace I'd been searching for answers and
I was just in such a state of turmoil
and I'm praying what is truth and then I
am overwhelmed by this sensation of love
and peace and I knew that God was love
and I thought well it has to be God then
for the next ten years Jessica pursued
that feeling full-time she immersed
herself in meditation taught yoga Reiki
energy healing and communication with
spirits seeking spiritual truths and
escalating along the spiritual path and
I viewed all religions and all modes of
spirituality as going up paths to the
mountain all different paths to the top
of the mountain and getting to the top
of that mountain was absolutely my top
priority in life but the closer Jessica
felt to achieving Nirvana the more her
personal life with her boyfriend fell
apart she struggled with anger and
unhappiness I didn't think any of the
tumultuous nests of our relationship was
spiritual I just needed to see a real
counselor and get to the root of the
issue which I viewed as my childhood you
know this is where this anger is coming
from
so she agreed to meet with Christian
counselor Donald and Don Offerman as
long as they didn't pressure her about
Jesus over dinner Jessica and her
boyfriend learned of the Offerman's
ministry to the homeless in Alaska I
started thinking well that's really cool
here are some people who are working
with Jesus the same way I'm working with
Buddha and Terra and these other
energies to do good Jessica decided
since Jesus was there for her during
childhood she should give him spiritual
priority
all of these other spirits really were
just acquaintances spirits compared to
that deep foundational relationship that
I had with Jesus as a child and I just
thought why am I not working with Jesus
and then I prayed something that I had
no idea how profound it was or what I
was setting into motion with my prayer I
prayed to all of the other spirits that
I've been working with I said thank you
so much for all that you have taught me
but from now on I'm just going to be
working with Jesus and I've done that
before with I'd worked with a certain
spirit or energy for a while there never
been any problems when I transition from
working with one to another and so I
just thought of course there would be no
problems there all beings of light after
all they just want what's best for me
Jessica and her boyfriend who had
recently become a Christian began
reading the Book of Luke aloud every day
neither of them was prepared for what
happened next I was sitting at the
kitchen table and all of a sudden out of
nowhere
I mean absolute nowhere I felt
just this overwhelming tear and hate and
evil just like overwhelming in an
instant out of nowhere and I knew
something very real was happening
spiritually in that moment I completely
surrendered and I knew that the only way
to be saved from what I had allowed into
myself was through Jesus Jessica asked
her boyfriend to pray in the name of
Jesus and the Lord brought to mine
verses that I hadn't thought of in a
really long time Satan himself
masquerades as an angel of light and I
knew it I knew in an instant that every
single word of the Bible was true not
just the ones that suited the way I want
him to live all of it
and in an instant I knew what it was and
it just started coming up and out and I
just consciously let it and this deep
throaty like
hiss came from the back of my throat and
I felt an energy leave Jessica
rededicated her life to Jesus Christ
that night and was set free from many
demonic spirits the Lord knew what
needed to happen and he allowed it to
happen he prepared me with his truths of
his scriptures and then he removed the
veil and let me experience the reality
of what I have allowed into myself
through these practices Jessica returned
to church where she grew in Christ she
met and married Stuart and they have two
sons
she says that the truth she was
searching for can only be found in one
place the peace that Jesus gave me was
this
deep true peace that wasn't a feeling I
came by faith and that's what I really
had to realize is that my relationship
with Jesus isn't about a feeling it's
about truce it's about faith even when
it's not comfortable it's about trusting
him that he is God and I'm not and that
he knows I'm submitting to that and then
I could look back throughout all the
years and all of the choices that I made
and I just saw his patience and how his
hand was always protecting me
[Music]
and he never gave up on me